calabar east nigeria for 20 years Audra
kallu has imported cloth but with the
country in deep economic crisis kallu
says the situation has never been worse
traders like him have to use expensive
black market dollars to buy their goods
and he has already had to let go of five
of his nine employees he holds president
Bihari responsible for the poor business
at the market in calabar I don't see any
hope yet I don't see anything that's it
oh looks as if he is going to change it
you know in the future so I think there
are two things involved if he's not
going to step down we as a nation or we
as a people will continue to leave in
this state until God knows when we are
living our feet in the hands of god to
Khamenei no do something I leave here
today softness of the people because the
government of worry is so insensitive to
the plight of the people one year after
the country's first democratic handover
many Nigerians are disappointed with
their new president critics accused
pahari of neglecting the ailing domestic
economy whilst taking numerous trips
abroad like this one to London where he
was feted as a corruption fighter the
president has answered them by saying
that the previous government had taken
all the state's money leaving him with
only one option to clean up the country
for the president that means above all
bringing corrupt politicians to justice
the most prominent case being that of
former National Security Advisor [ __ ]
Daisuke he stands accused of having
embezzled more than two billion dollars
even his critics agree President pukare
is serious about fighting corruption he
is known to be modest and upright and
being a former general he is highly
respected within the military an
important advantage for him in his fight
against Boko Haram so far boo hari has
not been able to keep his other election
promise to defeat the Islamists bloody
attacks continue but the army has
managed to retake large areas in the
north the Nigerian government says that
it now has the situation under control
and that the terrorist group is on the
run today they do not hold one thing
with no square meter of territory
they've been dislodged from their
fortresses they have been dispersed they
have been decimated and wrong blue
longer have the capacity to launch the
canova at I've used to launch for a
looky-loo the terror in the northeast of
the country is far away for him and his
colleagues all that matters is that his
customers come back he can't hold out
much longer in the hope of better
economic times if a turnaround doesn't
come soon his business could fold